[Music]
I work on the developer tools team hi my
name is Armas and I am from Android
toolkit team seems like everyone is very
awake which is great thanks for the
attention to you guys giving us anyway
so we're gonna be talking about building
bigger better from a perspective of a
big Gradle project Android X and as well
as Android studio we're here to
hopefully dispel the myth that you
cannot build big projects in Gradle so
every project starts simple but quickly
over as you add more and more features
it gets really complicated and for my
work on Chrome for Android and Android X
formerly known as support library I
learned that Android projects are just
the same they start as big monolithic
projects they grow over time and each
incremental change makes sense for some
context over the past 6 years
Android X drew from 5 to 240 Gradle
projects we went from 90 thousand lines
of code to over 400,000 we have an order
of magnitude more commits writing all
the cool libraries for you guys like
jetpack compose and others but as you
can imagine the initial Gradle config
just couldn't keep up with this it was
like not good enough of a setup so in
this talk we will focus on how we made
it better and how we improved so let me
state the obvious when it comes to
builds modularization is good you first
of all get more parallelism so you are
able to compile multiple projects at the
same time you also get more compilation
avoidance because Gradle is able to skip
certain libraries in cases for your
fetches you're often invalidating fewer
projects so you get more fewer cache
invalidations additionally you avoid
tangled dependencies that you get from
monolithic builds we definitely struggle
to that in android x4 libraries like
before we added a dozens of classes and
there was the dependencies Circulo a
so-called appendices but it made it
almost impossible to pull those
libraries apart into smaller pieces and
finally you get to test your libraries
easier because now your libraries live
the tests next to them so you exactly
know what to test when you make a change
in architecture components for example
we found that creating pure Java
libraries as a common layer between
other libraries was really helpful first
of all you get the separation from
Android API S which lets you run those
tests on a host which is really fast
it's now running on the phone
additionally you get faster builds
because by definition these Android non
Android Java and Kotlin projects are a
lot lighter
they don't hand variants they don't have
Android resources they don't have
manifest and so on so for your project
if you can pull out these kind of
projects I would highly recommend
starting with making them pure cotton or
Java Gradle plugin plugins can be great
but overusing them can cause you issues
and wasted work for example if you have
a greater plugin for publishing to maven
you really should be applying it to the
project that needs to publish to maven
otherwise you're creating all these
tasks and you will be wasting time
so modular ization here helps you to
apply these kind of plugins to a much
smaller scope so you're applying it to a
smaller project that you know leads to
faster builds similarly to the plugins
annotation processors can waste time
especially none on incremental type so
for example if you use Android X rule
library you should really pull the
libraries that need room into a separate
project and run the annotation processor
just on that project that way you
isolate on what the annotation processor
runs thus increasing your speed if your
project is an application you should
really consider running lint only in the
final project because Android while lint
is wireless amazing and finding bugs as
you do modularization you're going to be
running it on more and more projects
slowing it down however I want to note
if you do ship libraries I would highly
recommend continuing to run lint on
those libraries because things like
minimum SDK affect Howell endurance and
you will return different results and
help you catch bugs we introduced the
concept of API and implementation over
two years ago it allows you to specify
your dependencies as implementation
details which essentially helps the
compilation avoidance that I mentioned
before if you want to learn more about
that there's a recording from
from yesterday but Zab off the talk that
Jeb did so it's not all great there are
some downsides of doing the breakdown
and one of the obvious ones is you have
a large accordance II graph so Gradle
has to load up more built files that
figure out what's going on and what the
dependencies are but often these are
offset by the fact that you're doing a
lot of saving from all the things that I
described before
one thing that is not so easy and not so
obvious is that you have a lot more
build files now and this is one of the
things we struggled a lot in Android X
so a standard practice for in software
engineering is not to repeat yourself
and the same applies to build
configuration files less so less code is
simply easier to manage in Android X for
example if you wanted to bump to a new
version of espresso that meant touching
100 builder Gradle files and doing the
same manual change every place and it
was really error-prone when it was
really easy to make a mistake so these
kind of explicit versions made it
difficult to upgrade and also was
unclear of what versions are used across
the project so one option to kind of get
around that is to use Gradle extras as a
stash so it allows you to put strings on
this object and then you set it up in
your root builder Gradle file then to
utilize them you can put it in each
projects as builds the Gradle file and
then use it there this solves a
centralization problem and makes it
really easy to update so instead of
having to touch hundreds of files you
touch it on one place and now you have
updated version across throughout your
project it can be further extended to
use this kind of extra property for
other things as well so in Android X we
use this a lot and it was very helpful
but sadly you do not get things like
autocomplete and you do not get to click
through and see what the version you're
actually are setting so to get around
that there is a way
so Gradle offers you an implicit build
that gets automatically added to the
build class path what you need to do is
to create a build source directory and
ad builder Gradle in there and that
logic will automatically get built
before your real project
and you will get added to your build
class path
so solving the same dependencies for a
problem you can create a cotton file and
build source and just like in step one
you have the same thing but now you're
setting writing it all in cotton and
then similarly also refer to it in your
build our Gradle files we eventually
move to this style to specify all of our
dependencies in Android X it gives you
the same centralization benefits
you also get autocomplete and you get to
click through to see the versions that
you are actually using so we Android X
we found that there's way more
configuration that we found the same
from build file to build file to build
file and a lot of these who are coming
from Android Gradle plugin and that
Gradle the Android DSL so using extra
property like we did in the beginning
did not quite scale because you cannot
think create things like flavors and
stuff very easily at the root so brittle
handles configuration via plugins most
of the time and you can create one of
your own inbuilt source in Android X in
Android X we created one of them to set
the common properties that were common
across all the projects in in in this
slide the important part is to override
the apply method that's the one gets
called when you apply the plugin and
when you are applied you can react when
other plugins are added so for example
if Android Gradle plugin is added you
can react to it and then you can take
the extension which is essentially the
backing store that you can use in build
our Gradle files behind the Android DSL
and you can set things up so one thing
to note here you can have one custom
plug-in that you write that handles many
many external Pregnant's you don't need
to write one for each plug-in so in this
example this handles both Android
library plug-in and Android application
plugin and then as you get up you do
just get automatically set up so here
you have the same power as you had in
Android DSL in your build a cradle you
can set things like target SDK you can
set the default test run or enable
coverage and so on the two extensions
that you really care about our library
extension from the library plugin and
app extension from the application
plugin same is true for other plugins so
for example if you have a Java library
you
can also configure it in the same way
the only difference here that you have
to use a convention instead of an
extension it's very similar otherwise so
when you have this setup it's super easy
to apply and creating a new module
becomes trivial all your developers have
to do is throw in a few lines of code
and you and you're pretty much set so in
Android X specifically which you huge
gains of this we went to over from over
150 lines of code for build Gradle for
project to around 35 lines of code for
build our Gradle and considering we have
240 projects that's a huge savings
so in our plugin we set up things like
maven configuration for uploading we set
up Javadoc builds and and lint and other
uniform properties sadly we hit an issue
where if you want to do a custom
configuration just to one library for
example if one of your libraries has a
different minimum SDK version the set up
didn't really allow for that so we
needed to find a way to accommodate for
this kind of change so the first option
is just to set those custom values in
each library build a granule file in
this example we're setting a different
minimum SDK and different target Java
version in an Android X we did exactly
that so this is a real example from
lifecycle a runtime build up Gradle we
simply apply Android X plugin Android
library plugin we set up the
dependencies and just add some options
for Android DSL that are specific to
this library like this library actually
has ProGuard configs that we want to
ship inside of the AR one difference
here is we also created our own DSL that
allows us to tweak how our own plugin
works so when our plugin sets everything
up it reads these values and then we're
able to specify how our maven publishing
works so isn't it great to see all of
the configuration for one real
production library in two slides I sure
think so
and ZEB is gonna talk about how to set
up this custom Gradle DSL thank you
so let's say you want to configure your
own extension for your own plugin right
let's say let's take a very simple
example here you have your own plugin
and you just want to have my config with
one property in it so here I want to
proceed wanting to be a boolean notice
that there's no you know I'm using a
setter here and we're gonna see why in a
second so the first thing that you need
to do is to create an extension class
and this extension class is very basic
it doesn't need to extend anything and
so here I have it and I have my property
so notice two things the first one I'm
not declaring a boolean type I'm not
using a boolean type I'm using a
property boolean that is a new API in
greater that I introduced maybe about a
year ago and the second thing that you
can notice here is that I'm declaring
both the target the class and the
property as abstract so those property
object have to be instantiated in a very
special way and in order to do that
manually you have to inject a factory
into your class and it's really a lot of
boilerplate that you don't want to do so
studying ABI I think two versions of
greater ago if you declare your classes
as abstract
Grado is going to take care of it
because anyway what grader does is that
it never uses your type directly it'll
always extend your type and create a
decorated version of it and so here when
it creates that new type it's going to
take care of instance shading all the
property properties of type property
something so the way you instantiate it
is just this way called project
extension create or reverse this example
had a project extension get by type so
here we create it the string is called
my config this is what will show up on
your DSL and you provide the type the
instance that that method return is not
exactly my plug-in extension it's going
to be the decorated version but you
don't have to care you can just keep
manipulating your tasks all the things
that's added on top of it you don't
really have to worry about it so now you
want to use that you want to use that
value that you set in the DSL into a
task as an input and so here I'm
creating a task
I have a property and I'm also setting
the type of the property to be property
of boolean this is very important
I'm also declaring it as abstract and
the task also type instead of being just
a regular open type that you would have
to do I'm declaring it as abstract so
that greater can decorate it and do the
right thing for me next I want to
actually register my tasks using the
lazy API so register and a callback
that's a lambda that gets called
whenever your tasks get coffee good and
here I'm sitting onto my tasks property
the property coming from my extension
I'm not setting the value I'm not doing
my config dot super sleuth warning dot
yet if you do that you lose some of the
benefits and so by using the property
directly you're basically doing your
lazy binding between the two so what
happens is that this code here the
register really is likely to happen you
apply and your apply is at the very top
of your bill operator so if you change
the value later it's important that you
do not set the value in the apply
because then if you change the value
later then the task will have the old
value so by using properties you
guarantee that whenever you're actually
configuring your task or whenever you're
setting the last value in the DSL at the
end your task will have the letters
value anyway so this is a new feature of
Gradle and it's really efficient and
should really use property everywhere ok
let's look at other tips to really
configure your project in the most
efficient way possible so when we talk
about configuration you know the first
advice that I have is really do as
little as possible I see a lot of people
who do a lot of things in their bill
they have 150 line in their beloved
Gradle and they do crazy things in there
and this is the cost you're gonna pay
right every time you call integrator
whether you're thinking doing a build
querying for the list of tasks you're
going to pay that cost so it's important
that you do as little as possible
another advice is try to you know see
what you can do that in release but not
do it in debug right you have those bill
types by default we see a lot of people
doing way too much in debug that they
don't need to do don't do it and in on
CI make sure that you only build
whatever you actually need we see people
calling a Samba
and that builds way more than date so
around configuration of tasks you know I
just show you the tasks that register
and it's particularly important to use
the lazy API because in Android by
default you have five balance right for
each module you have debug release and
then three test violent so it creates a
lot of tasks here in the example that I
have hundred module it's nineteen
thousand tasks you don't want to create
and configure all of them so we're
already doing that what's important for
you is two things first when you create
your own tasks create them lazy D and
second when you use API is from Gradle
or from the android plug-in use the
proper API right there's a lot of legacy
API that returns a tasks instance and we
have them in a GPU like you know in your
variants you can do get compile that
returns the compiled tasks if you use
that it's gonna create them it's got a
first configure it crater lies near API
that's returned the task provider and we
have new API is written you know get
compiled provider that returns a test
provider that's a lazy object so you
should use that the second thing I want
to talk about is tasks wiring right if
you're creating a lot of custom tasks
you probably have to do some depends on
and that's very fragile and really you
shouldn't do it let's say you have a
depends on B and then later you change a
to actually dependency if you don't pay
attention you may depend on B and C and
that's not what you want so the old way
of doing this is you know you have two
tasks when the generate an output
directory right and the type of the
property is fine and attest to that
consumes that directory and it has a
property of type file as well and so the
way you configure those two tasks is on
the first one you do register output my
location on the second one you do in
pedir equal okay so normally before
right if it did not have lazy
configuration you could do task 1 dot
output here right you just link those
two locations directly you can't really
do that in lazy configuration so you
have to kind of either duplicate it or
use another class that you know
centralize all your location computation
which is something we used to do in a GP
a long time ago and then you do a manual
depends on right so the first thing is
not great then the second one is
definitely terrible you should
do that you might be thinking well it's
just next line so if I update the
location the value of input di I will
remember to change the depends on but
the reality is that it's more likely to
be somewhere else at leaning the greater
plug in it was definitely in a lot of
somewhere else and so we moved away from
all of that so great early in the last
year after they introduced the property
type they really improved a lot that so
let's see what it looks like and what's
the best practice today first your task
1 you're going to change it and the
property is not gonna be directory
property and also I mean you know I'm
using also directory property on the
second one and of course I use the
abstract way so that greater takes care
of instantiating all of those objects
for me so directory property is very
interesting it's it's actually a
property of directories similar to
property bull that I showed earlier
so it's you know dynamic and lazy in the
same way that the other one is but it
also include test dependency information
even though when you look at the type
hierarchy it doesn't really show
anything but the Javadoc says hey it
includes test dependency information so
let's see how I'm gonna use that oh and
by the way you see that it's actually
directory there is a matching regular
file properties so the European is a
more precise and you cannot link to task
one that generates a directory the other
one that we do file anymore because it's
it's type safely so setting up task 1
it's very similar I would put the offset
and then the value so no difference
there on a task 2 what I'm doing is the
same way I did with the tasks and the
extension earlier when I'm sitting on
one property the other property directly
to make a link between them I want to do
that too but here because I'm a lazy
task while the the abuse easy way or
lazy way to do it is to say well task 1
that get and then I get the profit well
it's not lazy at all actually because
it's gonna first configure your task
which is not something you want to do so
task 1 and test 2 our type of type tasks
provider and they have this thing called
flat map so what flat map does it
returns a provider of a directory
provider being the
parent type of property and it's a
read-only type and so this is lazy it's
gonna encapsulate the property of task 1
and it's going to propagate the value in
a lazy way but it's also going to
propagate the dependency lazy and so now
input the automatically depends on task
1 sorry touch 2 directly depend on task
1 I don't have to do anything if I
change input do to be set to a different
value then it will automatically change
my dependency so when you extract
flatmap into an artifact a value that's
very interesting because this thing now
represent the artifact and whatever's
needed to build it and you don't have to
care about the how which is you know
keeping track of task 1 so imagine you
have a task that output two things and
you have some code that use those two
things and then later you change that
task to actually the two tasks each that
generate one thing if you're already
using the provider of directory or
provide a regular file you don't have to
care you don't have to keep track of the
task you just keep track of this
artifact and then you just read it it
doesn't matter who create it and it's
updated this is something that's very
powerful and that make code much cleaner
this is something that internally in the
Gradle plugin we're moving to out and
that I think it will have we expose that
as a public API at some point okay so in
my previous talk yesterday we talked
about worker api jerome talked about it
explained how things are less efficient
if you have tasks that are not using
worker and tasks that are using worker
so please go look at the talk and the
message for you today is if you have
custom tasks please use the worker api
look at the api online on the greater
side it's not that difficult and you
should really do it another thing that i
wanna mention is you know when you
create tasks always create a custom type
it may seem like easier to use some of
the api rocket that Gradle has like you
could do something like that like hey I
have a task and I'm just configuring it
and saying here do this thing it looks
okay right you know and there's some
trick between the groovy DSL and the kts
DSL you know and you might be thinking
like there's the right thing but if you
were to actually use a
default typed from Gradle and try to
extend it you would realize that
actually you know you're doing expensive
code whatever it is directly in the
configuration so every time you build
you're actually going to do what your
task is supposed to do this is not good
right
so the real rocket would now be tasked
do last expensive and it so it doesn't
look as well anyway and then do last
cannot use workers you can't really
declare inputs or outputs and so the
best practice is always you know create
your own type declare input declare
outputs and use workers if you don't do
it you're basically not building as
efficiently as you should now talking
about doing things during configuration
that you shouldn't do really you know we
see a lot of people trying to do like a
lot of computation and it's really not
something that you should be doing now I
realize that we don't have awesome ideas
to let you do some of the things that
you want to do but I'm gonna run you
through a two example that kind of
explain some workarounds to do a better
job so the first one that is by far the
one that we see most people do is
putting get information into the Russian
code or version name so we see something
like that Russian code equal and then
call in to get and get the Hedgehog on
or whatever and it's just not efficient
at all again you're gonna do that every
time you think every time you call
greater just to do you know like hey
what's the list of tasks or what's my
dependency is it's just not efficient so
as I said we don't really have a better
way to do it or nice way but there are
some ways to do it so the answer should
always be I need to do it in a task so
here because it's not very easy the way
that I found is well the version code is
injected in the manifest merger so if at
the end of the manifest merger I go and
I inject the version it should work so
the solution looks like this I'm gonna
run you through it so the first thing is
that you're going to have to read the
version code and and put it in you're
going to read you have to read the
manifest file and so since I'm a little
bit lazy and I don't want to use a full
XML library and find the attributes I'm
just going to do a search on replace so
I said version code two
a lot of nines hopefully it's not a
string that is present multiple times in
my file the next thing is I need to loop
over all of my variants right you always
have to do if you did with test you have
multiple balance you have to deal with
them and then also the manifest merger
is part of the output because of multi
apk if you use splits and things like
that here I don't have any so I'm just
going to loop on them but I knew I would
only have one and then I use sorry I use
manifest merger provider right remember
earlier I said don't use the known
provider version so here I get manifest
provider rich on a test provider and I
can call configure which just register a
lambda to run whenever the task is
configured later so it's lazy so inside
that add a duelist so you know I said
earlier workers but I that's the only
solution I have right now and then
inside it's very easy right the first
thing I do is I read the manifest
so here the manifest merger actually has
a property which is a directory property
manifest output directory so it's a get
and then as fine and then I just read
the file I do a search and replace and
I've read it back and if you do that it
will actually work now there are some
things that you need to tweak a little
bit right like if you do a git commit
touching let's here with me file you're
get jhanas change your headshot - change
but your code hasn't so you need to
technically recompile caching also is
important to use the input so you need
to do a little bit more work and so on
greater on tests you can create new
inputs so here I declare a new input the
name has to be unique I put something
random here and then you pass the value
and again it has to be lazy so don't put
the actual value put a callable that
will do the value so that grader can
call that whenever you need that the
last thing here is that what I ended up
cutting compute value twice inside and
during input validation so you
technically should extract that into a
callable memorize it somehow and in fact
I should probably put that one above my
application loop because I need to I
don't want to do that for post debug and
release some caveats here you know the
model is not up to date so if you have
another plug-in that use version code
it's not gonna get the value but here I
use a value as an in
generally you want to use a file but the
input here should be the get index which
can be really big so do I want to do a
check sum of all of it
maybe using jiggy's I can get the value
faster so up to you figure it out
and then don't last do last don't use
worker in fact you know they don't use
worker and they don't work very well
with worker right so if you have your
tasks here and you add a worker at the
end if the task user worker the do last
doesn't that means that if and all the
tasks run in at the same time it can
move to last actually and schedule it a
bit later so if you look at earlier
scans the the time of the creation of
the the tasks might be bigger than it
seems but it but it is because of that
white space in the middle something to
think about okay so we have another
example which is you know we see people
passing data ya buildconfig
for example the computer value and they
put it there so here it's harder to hook
in to the end and actually you know add
to the class so you can generate your
own class so I know that to do that it's
very easy you create a task so some
input package name class name location
and then the value and then I mean the
generation is relatively easy right I'm
just generating a four line Java class
so it's not nothing to talk about the
part about that we wanna look at is how
I register it right so again I loop on
the variance
I create my task with a unique name
using the variant name and then I set
the value here again using something
lazy so provider a project that provider
which you know received a call able and
returned a provider object basically so
that it's lazy and it's gonna work out
of the box the last thing you need to do
is you need to set you need to tell us
that hey I have generated some Java code
please go and compile it pass it to
studio so that I don't have unreserved
symbols and suddenly your IP I to do
that receive tests and not test provider
so we need to update that to make that
lazy task compatible so you will have to
actually go and call on your test
provider to get which we configure it
right away which is not great but it's
better than doing the computation during
during the configuration
now walk you through a little bit of the
guided 2 investigations of how do you
want to go about profiling measuring and
optimizing your bills so bill scans is a
really great tool that is provided by
Gradle the company behind Grail it's
really simple to use you run the same
task to normally do you just simply add
- - scan at the end that will and it
will prompt you to accept a license and
then it will upload your results for
analysis the important caveat to note
here this does send the data to Gradle
servers so you should be comfortable
over doing that they do give you an
option to delete all the results after
you're done and now your analysis but
you should just be aware of them you're
doing this so the reason why this tool
is really helpful it helps you find
those non lazy tasks that as I was
talking about and as well
you can find where your dependencies
that get resolved during the
configuration time which is another big
no-no so in yesterday's talk if you saw
Sam was talking about a 100 module like
baseline build right and then this is
how it compares to Android X so this is
a real project that has 240 modules and
is able to configure it in 24
milliseconds for a project so if you're
seeing your builds of you know 45 you
know 50 modules taking 10 seconds 20
seconds there's definitely ways to
improve and make it better so all I'm
saying is get inspired right so this is
only 6 milliseconds worse than a
baseline project and one thing to note
here but you can see in the slides that
we're not even doing that many lazy task
configurations that just means we
haven't done the work to actually make
it as fast as it can be so in Android X
will actually use build scans in another
way we used it to investigate the
effects of JVM max memory limits we
wanted to see how does that affect our
project right and for our project it
turned out to be the biggest bang for
the buck potentially new studio projects
start with one and a half gig limit for
your Gradle JVM and that might not be
enough for your project so what you want
to do is you really want to run an
experiment where you try the different
values and see how that comes out in
terms of to get the optimal value of
speed versus memory usage the things you
want to do you want to run the - - rerun
tasks that forces you to run
the tasks otherwise you might be
skipping some tasks due to caching and
stuff like that and now we'll give you
incorrect results you want to kill
demons in between the runs because if
you don't the Gradle demon will stay
stick around and cause you memory
pressure also leading to incorrect
results another thing to run is you want
to run tasks that are common to your
developers so if your developer does
assemble debug all the time that's the
path you should optimize for and then
finally and probably more importantly is
you want to run it on a typical
developer machine if you're gonna test
it out on the beefy machine and then
developer is gonna rather run it on a
different one you're not gonna have the
same performance characteristics so as
you play around with JVM memory limit
you just want to use Bill scans and see
how the execution time and garbage
collection times what the ratio is so
here in Android X we did a scan and
takes five minutes to GC and the total
build of nine minutes that means we're
only doing like four minutes of valuable
work and the rest of it is just garbage
collecting and that's bad that's what
the state where we're in before we
started investigating there's obviously
like hard limits of how small the memory
can be if you try to build Android X or
one gig of memory allowed after 14
minutes of struggling it will just throw
out a memory exception so as we did the
test you can see in the graph 1 & 2 gigs
we're simply just not a thing that you
can do and that four gigs were wasting a
lot of time garbage collecting we ended
up picking number eight gigabytes for us
because that was the best in terms of
but to developer machines that we had
available and the speed we were able to
achieve as you can see there's
diminishing returns as you give Gradle
more memory there will be less garbage
collection but there's a you should
really pick a value and note don't just
take heed gigabytes instead in your
project this is for our project you
should do your own experiment and kind
of run it yourself another leathery you
have to pull is number Gradle workers so
Gradle by default gives you in a number
of workers as you have processors and
that might be too many for you because
what happens is the more workers you
spin up the more memory is being used at
the same time and if you don't have
enough memory you port your computer to
go into garbage collection all the time
so potentially limiting the number of
workers I know it sounds kind of
intuitive but it might make your builds
faster and you essentially want to run
the same process of experimentation that
we did for max
memory and finally one thing do you want
to notice for your CI you probably
should be picking different values for
the maximum JVM limits as well for max
workers and the reasons are your CI
probably runs away more tasks in
different tasks your build machines do
and also you probably have maybe fewer
machines of a more CPU and more RAM and
Zab is gonna walk you through how to use
a tracer agent to do more debugging
thank you okay so yesterday I mentioned
that you should really profile your
configuration right especially if you
apply a lot of plugin now if you have
your own plugin so of course you can use
any Java profiler but we found that you
know that was probably a better way a
more user-friendly way to profile that
so we created this little tool called
tracer agent that you can go and
download from a repository you can
really look at the readme see everything
but basically it works two different
ways right one way is you can create
some custom events you know using the
API or you can just you know anybody to
attach it to your JVM it's gonna run
inside it and you provide it with a list
of things to instrument and then at the
end it's going to output a JSON file
that you can just load in the chrome
tracing tool and see everything that
happens so I did that with the little
plugin that I made for this demo about
like the manifest merger do last and the
little generate code for build config
and things like that so what I did here
is I set it up to instrument everything
in my custom package right and then I
added a couple of lines to instrument a
few method from Gradle to see some life
cycle between configuration and
execution and a few of our own methods
in order to also instrument and see
what's happening in the grader plugin so
you load that into Chrome and then you
see all the colors and you're wondering
what's happening so if we dig into the
configuration phase we see the green the
large green banner at the top is the
whole configuration phase and then you
can you know zoom in and you can see
that this tiny little line here is the
apply plugin of my own plugin right so I
do very little here great but then you
can see that you have those two lines
and if I
the name it says custom plugins out
something that's my code - in fact it's
whenever you do Android that application
Valiant at all you're just registering
callback to happen later whenever the
Gradle plugin create those variants and
then call you back
so it doesn't show up in my apply
plug-in it shows up somewhere else
that's why this tool is great because
you say show me where that method is you
know taking time wherever it is I don't
have to go and backtrack it where it's
coming from
so here it's got twice and it's the
method called you know generate create
generate code tasks so that's my second
example that I showed about and it's
taking a large amount of time compared
to like the whole pink line which is
create honorary tasks and it just for
one task right so what happens here is I
left a thread sleep 100 millisecond so
that it shows up there but basically you
can go and really look to see where your
code is another example this is during
execution phase and again you know you
don't really see anything else normally
it should be like a waterfall chart but
here it only shows you basically the end
and it's my computer version code so
what and I can see that it's called
three times
so I mentioned you know so turns out
that the first two are actually greater
doing up-to-date checks and coding the
method to be like hey what's the current
version compared to the old one and then
the third one is the execution and so
you know I mentioned during earlier
during my slide that you know you needed
to memorize it and here obviously I did
not do it and therefore I see to run
three times and so that's very useful so
the good thing here is that you can
basically instrument any plugin right if
you apply a bunch of plug-in go look at
their source you know just open the jar
see what the package name is just add
the package name it's going to
instrument all the plug-in and then you
can just run a regular build look at
just JSON file see where you're spending
a lot of time and figure out what your
configuration is way above the baseline
that you know RMS and I showed you right
right
I've talked to people telling me I have
like few dozen modules and I have thirty
per second configuration and this is not
normal right you should be way faster
than that so I highly recommend that you
use this tool or any other Java profiler
to really figure out why you're spending
so much time and with that thank you we
be at the sandbox if you have questions
and thank you for coming
[Applause]
[Music]